I will teach you how do you use one
such bill tool which is called Grant and
I'm going to help you
get started with Grant.
So right now what I have actually cloned
the project into my local depository.
It actually resides inside
the downloads folder.
I'm going to open my terminal and
install something called node js.
Node js is a scalable application that
will help you create all the necessary
bill tool requirements, all the files
that you need for your optimization.
So right now what I have to do is,
you can go to node JS and
directly install it from here.
So if you go to the downloads,
you can see
that you have Windows Installer,
a Mac and you have the Source Code.
So since I'm on a Mac,
I am going to be installing that
package that is already given to me.
What I'm going to do is I am going
to initialize an npm command
into my project repository.
So, to initialize npm,
I need a JSON file that will
actually point me to
the name of the project and
the dependencies I am giving for
this project.
For example,
you now see my package.json open,
which I have actually put
inside my root directory.
So what package.Json essentially
has is a name for my grant project,
so I just named it example project,
and I've given it a version.
This is going to be my first 1.0
version so that is the version number.
And there isn't dependencies
that you have to provide,
which is called depth dependencies which
tells you which bill tool I'm using.
So you have a lot of bill tools, Grunt,
so I'm going to be using Grunt, and
I have specified the version of Grunt,
4.1 and
above versions are going
to be supported.
So, right now what I'm going
to do is single npm install.
So I did a pseudo npm install,
just install npm Cmd,
what I do after the npm
install is to run from CLI.
And once that is done what I have
to do is, I have a file called
gruntfile.js, which again
you guys will be creating,
something where you'll actually
specify all the Grunt modules that you
are going to be importing to use
Grunt to run specific tasks.
So for instance,
I am going to use an [INAUDIBLE]
package [LAUGH] that is going
to glittify my JS files.
[CROSSTALK] Yeah,
that's what you call it, glittify.
So as you can see, it says
model.sports = functionGrants, so
this is going to be the grant file
that the Grunt function, it's going to
take in and it's going to look at
all the tasks that I have defined.
So it says that I am going to build on
this source, which is this JS file, and
the destination is going to be this
JS file and then I'm going to load
the npm tasks using this package, and
then I'm going to register this task.
So when I run the Grunt command, it is
supposed to run this [INAUDIBLE] package
and it is going to give you a minified
version of your JavaScript.
The next step of this would be to
actually install this package.
So, the same dependencies is
actually going to save the package
name into your Json file.
So, I'm going to copy it, and
what I'll do is I will take re-space
this with the [INAUDIBLE] 5 package
that I have installed right here.
And I'm going to replace this name
here and then give a save give.
So let's see what this returns.
Hopefully this will execute and
it says I have an error.
So it says please try running this
command as a root or an administrator.
But I probably should have
to give pseudo since I am
authorizing it as the root.
So once I do that, I feel like
Couplify is going to load and
it looks like Couplify got installed.
I can check this by going into my
package.Json and you can see this here.
[INAUDIBLE] shows up here.
After this, ones that I have
actually downloaded the package,
I just run Grunt from here.
And it's going to take it and
it says running [INAUDIBLE],
one file created,
which should be my minified file.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going
to navigate inside my JS as you can
see I have my minified
file that Grunt created.
So as you can see,
you have other packages on Grunt,
like image minification,
HTML minification,
JSint of packages, and other ones
that will help you go ahead and
actually making your content and
your website efficient and
render efficiently-
>> So
what's the reason to use Grunt, right?
Like it seems like a fair amount of
work to get set up, doesn't Grunt?
But then what's the value?
Why do people do it?
>> So one thing is Grunt helps
you separate your development and
production version of code.
So you still get to keep the unminified
code which is very useful for
development, right.
>> Right.
>> Minified code is not readable,
you're not able to see what
you've actually created, so
it's going to be very ugly.
You need to unminify it and then use it.
But with Grunt, you can get to
keep your development code and
produce a set of other code that can
be used to run your website there.
So that is one reason why
you have to use Grunt-
>> So given how often we make changes to
our projects that we might have to
start, when we start a project,
we want to just get something going.
We iteratively develop,
we incrementally build up.
So each time you can kind of test
your code, you can just run Grunt,
it builds everything.
With your production-level website
codes, you can push it out, it runs, but
then when you want to make changes,
you just run Grunt again rather than
having to manually minify every time or
on each of your scripts.
It manages all of that for
you, so it's worth the setup,
it's worth doing these stages at
the beginning of your project, and
then the more you do
it the easier it gets.
>> Yeah, and this file can be used for
your other projects as well,
your package.Json and your Gruntfile.JS,
can be used for your other codes.
Only that you have to alter the path
that you give inside that you
are targeting.
But you can use those as a standard for
all your projects, for
building your production code.